c'était le 28 juin dernier véronique
matillon candidat divers droite devient
maire de rambouillet 46 84 % des
suffrages
après avoir été en charge de la
commission petite enfance et adjointe au
maire aux scolaires et à la famille sur
les deux mandats précédents elle succède
à marc robert le maire sentant qu'il
avait soutenu je ne m'y attendais pas je
n'ai pas de carrière politique en vue ni
vraiment une mission que je prends avec
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'intérêt je
suis passionné par ce que je fais on me
l'avait dit et bien mes prédécesseurs me
l'avait dit et je confirme c'est
vraiment passionnant
après avoir été intronisé en juillet
dernier véronique mathieu on devient
officiellement la seconde femme maire de
la ville de rambouillet après jacqueline
tome patenôtre sur ce mandat dans les
yvelines elle est également l'une des
seule femme maire d'une ville de plus de
25000 habitants
j'estime que le fait d'être une femme
c'est un débat parce que je suis une
femme que je suis maire qu'on l'entende
bien je pense que ça prouve que en tant
que femme travaillant mère de famille eh
bien on peut réussir aussi à accéder à
ces postes pendant la semaine véronique
mathieu on se déplace sur le terrain ce
lundi 5 octobre la nouvelle vers se rend
dans cette résidence pour seniors à
l'occasion de la semaine bleue les
venues participer à un déjeuner et un
loto c'est très important les seniors
pour moi c'est une génération qui a son
importance je suis infirmière en
gérontologie
donc c'est un public pour lequel j'ai
beaucoup d'affection
beaucoup datent h et je pense qu'il est
vraiment très important de leur montrer
à quel point nous avons besoin d'eux et
à quel point ils sont aussi toute
l'histoire de notre vie de notre ville
de notre pays
des rencontres qui s'organise dans des
semaines chargées pour la nouvelle élue
de 57 ans j'avais posé comme condition
de pouvoir continuer à travailler parce
que je suis très attaché à mon métier
d'infirmière en gérontologie
je travaille le lundi au réseau le mardi
de 9h à 17h ce qui me permet de venir en
mairie avant d'aller au bureau s'il le
faut et surtout de venir en mairie
après
ma journée de travail c'est une deuxième
journée qui s'entame mais ça se fait
tout à fait bien au planning millimétré
la femme politique devra faire avec
pendant plusieurs années même si elle
veut vivre au jour le jour véronique
patier on ne refuse pas de se
représenter dans six ans lors des
prochaines municipales pour mener à bien
les différents projets de la commune